foreign
six months to a year besides having 20
down what other tips would you recommend
for a first-time homebuyer also is there
anything that I need to look out for
um yeah I would say there's a couple of
things to keep in mind I think it's
great that you're putting 20 percent
down uh we would say to do a deal where
your payment is no more than 25 percent
of your take home and that's taxes
Insurance all included in a conventional
loan and I love that you're putting 20
down because then you can avoid PMI
which is private mortgage insurance and
it's just an additional cost there but
with 20 down you can avoid that but I
feel like you're in pretty good shape I
mean other than that it sounds sounds
pretty good to me yeah a couple of
things good idea good question by the
way 15-year fixed rate 25 of your
take-home pay
um always
everyone
anytime you buy a piece of real estate
get title insurance
100 of the time
anytime you're buying a piece of
property that is not a traditional
subdivision lot
meaning it's very very predictable
always get a survey
so if you you know about three acres it
turned out to be 1.75 no that yeah no we
uh we you get a survey on it okay now
you got a standard subdivision lot that
is pre-platted and has changed hands
three or four times you don't have to
worry about that it is what it is but uh
if you're buying something otherwise get
a survey get title insurance and get a
home inspection
get a home inspection you're 20 years
old you're not an expert on much of
anything in that house uh unless you're
just I happen to be an electrician or
something and then you would be right
but
um yeah get it get a home inspection
period
um I've bought and sold several thousand
pieces of real estate I get a home
inspection last house I bought I got one
okay
um I can go in there and scratch around
in the crawl space and try to figure it
out but for what it costs to let
somebody else do it right
um
that's the thing uh don't buy a house
that is a great price but is ugly
from the street
first house I bought was that I got a
great deal and this house was
ugly from the street
there's no fixing ugly yeah you can't
fix ugly okay it's just still gonna be
no well we could we could no don't don't
don't don't try to fix ugly ugly you
just look like you you know oh I had
plastic surgery and you shouldn't have
bothered oh don't do it you know I mean
I mean don't you just can't fix it leave
it alone just don't don't it's not a
good buy because if you get a good buy
on it now when you get ready to sell it
you know what you have an ugly house
and you're gonna give somebody else a
good deal because nobody wants an ugly
house so that there's a reason it was
cheap when you bought it and there'll be
a reason it's cheap when you sell it so
good and that's also true with the
actual floor plan
I bought a house one time no actually I
didn't buy I rented it one time that was
a four bedroom but to get to one of the
bedrooms you had to walk through the
other bedroom oh yeah that's terrible
we used to call these country built
houses where you just keep adding on
and you just go yeah well there there
was actually no plan from the beginning
yeah and then you've got no plan so be
careful with that kind of stuff you can
you can get excited particularly on your
first buy and uh try to buy something
that's a little bit boring
that's good advice you know don't try to
like reinvent the world I'm gonna do a
rehab oh God no well I mean you could
pick you could pick something that's got
things that you can fix like if the
carpet's super ugly there's things that
are outdated like you can you can change
that but you can put you can put the
gutters up that's fine but don't tell me
you got to change though no yeah I gotta
tear out I gotta add no no no no no no
no just you just boring means less risk
going in and less risk going out and so
a nice little house with a little picket
fence and little bushes out front and it
looks you look at it from the street and
everybody goes oh that's cute that's
that's where you want to start what do
you think about Corner Lots because when
we bought in our neighborhood before we
came here we thought we had a good luck
because we were on the corner by the
gate and for us it was great we thought
oh we could take the dog out it's easy
access but then when we got ready to
sell
are a mixed blessing because generally
Corner Lots present well from the street
right but you have no freaking backyard
you got this little tiny triangle back
there where they crammed the house back
inside at a 45 and so it depends on the
subdivision depends on the lot size
right all those kinds of things but
generally speaking you get a nice
presentation from the front and then
you're pinched in the back yeah that's
generally what you'll get so watch for
that that's not the end of the world but
watch for that again if you've got a
concern when you're looking at it know
that they're the buyer when you get
ready to sell it's going to have the
same concern so just don't right don't
get so excited you rationalize your way
into stupidity I know a guy who's done
that a lot in his life and um that's how
he has a radio show so be careful